hello if you have found the ideas i
discussed
interesting and useful perhaps you might
consider purchasing my recently released
book beyond order 12 more rules for life
available from penguin random house in
print
or audio format you could use the links
we provide below or
buy through amazon or at your local
bookstore
this new book beyond order provides what
i hope is a productive and
interesting walk through ideas that are
both philosophically and
sometimes spiritually meaningful as well
as being
immediately implementable and practical
beyond order can be read and understood
on its own
but also builds on the concepts that i
developed in my previous books
12 rules for life and before that
maps of meaning thanks for listening
and enjoy the podcast
[Music]
today almost 70 years after brown versus
board of education
ushered in the civil rights movement
there is an urgent need to reaffirm and
advance its core principles
fair is the foundation against
intolerance and racism
fair gets that our civil rights and
liberties need to be protected it's not
enough
just to be anti-racist we also need to
be pro-human
to insist on our common humanity to
advocate for fairness and understanding
to demand that we are each entitled to
equality
under law to bring about a world in
which we are
all judged by the content of our
character and not by the color of our
skin
that's where fair comes in moving
forward
together as one race the human race
i support fair i support fair i support
support i support faith support i
support
fair join us
i'm pleased to have with me today mr
paul
rossi paul rossi is a high school
mathematics teacher
and writer he graduated from cornell
university
with a ba in french literature in 1992
and from hunter college in new york city
with an m.a in educational psychology in
he's been teaching mathematics including
algebra 2
and calculus at grace church high school
in manhattan
since 2012 his april 2021 essay
i refuse to stand by while my students
are indoctrinated
was recently published on stacks common
sense with
barry weiss ms weiss is a former new
york times journalist who resigned
over differences with her employer and
began to function as an independent
investigative writer on sub stack
thank you very much for agreeing to talk
with me today
it's a pleasure to be here
what's your life like at the moment
uh well i have a little more time than
than usual at this point i would
you know be teaching classes um uh
you know i would have you know up to
three classes a day but they've
they've taken my classes away um and
assigned them to
some other folks and uh so i i basically
have no more teaching duties right now
um so i have a lot of time for volunteer
work and some other
other things like this uh which has been
you know
a good chance to tell my story okay so
you're working at
at grace um at
sorry it's grace grace church high
school and
walk us through what happened you you're
a mathematics teacher there
and you published an essay with barry
weiss
uh last week and
tell us about the school first
well we're we're k through 12 school
that opened up a high school
in 2012 so that um
well it was it was k through eight and
then they opened in ninth grade and then
as the ninth moved to the tenth and they
brought in another ninth grade and so
we we had a complete high school by
2016.
and you know our high school is
um it's a prep school um but over over
the course of
the you know particularly the last five
years we've
you know five six years we've been
implementing um
an anti-racist uh curriculum programming
uh
for our students as well as you know
because as we were told in 2015
diversity equity and inclusion is not
enough and
we needed to move towards a so-called
anti-racist
um pedagogy and program so that was
beyond diversity inclusivity and equity
right it's a private it's a private high
school private high school that's right
it's called independent the tuition is
approximately how much a year
i believe that's up to 57 000 a year i
think
um i could it's somewhere between 50 and
60. and how big a school is it
uh well our high school has about 340
students in it um and
you know maybe 100 120 faculty i'm not
really sure
what the ratio is my faculty and staff
did you enjoy teaching there i did i
love teaching math
um i it's just it's a wonderful thing
and i
you know i didn't i got into teaching
math late
um but it's it's something that i really
enjoy
uh this year has been hard because we've
been teaching i've been teaching hybrid
which means i teach uh both on zoom
um or you know i guess until recently uh
and to students in the classroom
simultaneously
so that's been a technical challenge
it's also been you know a challenge to
keep
you know everybody engaged and also to
to focus my attention where it needs to
be
um so this has been a difficult year
yes i imagine so um would you
have considered your relationships with
you your faculty peers
and the administration and the students
was that essentially positive
during the duration of your tenure as a
teacher there
yeah i mean i would say it has been
positive i mean my colleagues
um they sort of know where i stand i
haven't
i haven't sort of i haven't taken great
pains to hide my thinking
um in some cases i've gotten into some
spats with
with them over you know differences in
the way that the programming has been
delivered
um and you know the essentially the
foundations
the belief the system of belief which
animates it
but i will say you know i've had very
cordial relations with
you know the dean of equity and
inclusion and the office of community
engagement as people
you know i find i finally get along
and with the students and the students
you know i had a difficult
first couple years as a teacher i did
took me some time to really
settle on a personality that worked for
me but i kind of
you know by hooker by crook uh you know
worked out a kind of performative self
that that
functioned well well enough uh you know
to
to teach what teach pretty well i mean i
won't say i'm i'm
i'm excellent teacher i'm i'm decent i'm
pretty good by now but you know it has
taken a while
and is this something that you had
planned to continue pursuing did
did you see yourself apart from let's
say this incident did you see yourself
in
the teaching profession yeah i yeah i
could i could um i
was thinking i would i would want to be
a teacher for the duration you know
and uh and i i didn't
really ever consider leaving teaching um
until until probably this year
what did you like about teaching
uh i like the energy
yeah i i like the energy of the students
and i like to
to um you know communicate
with them about you know what i find
true and beautiful about mathematics
mathematics is
was for me personally when i when i got
back into it and teaching
i found that it was a sort of island in
the storm uh the storm of the culture
wars and
the sort of general the epistemological
um chaos which you know which i find you
know in
in language and discourse right because
you had a
you have a b a b a in french literature
and i i can't i don't presume that your
m and ed psych was math focused but i
could be wrong
was it no it was not it wasn't okay so
it's interesting that you
that you ended up teaching math and also
it's interesting that you founded an
island in a storm
and i suppose that the way that you talk
about it makes it sound like that was a
relief
yeah from what exactly um
well uh it's it's a bit of a long story
uh
at cornell um i studied the humanities i
had a history major english major and
french lit major
as an undergrad and me and my my merry
band of friends and cohort of of uh
you know compatriots we were
really into post-modernism we really
loved the
the paradoxes of language we studied
daridan foucault and
and leotard and beaudrillard and there
was a certain
like enthusiasm even a lust for paradox
that we had and
i i personally had reading texts and
sort of
finding out how words can mean their
opposite how meanings can be
seen to be taken different ways and
i guess i would say that my
i guess i had a kind of a breakdown from
that and that i didn't really
once i realized i didn't want to become
a professor or go into
um you know the academic world because i
found that even then it was
i was being pushed to say things i
didn't believe
i you know i kind of drifted for
a decade i would i would say trying to
find
something that was meaningful so back
when you were
an undergraduate you found the
postmodernists
emotionally motivationally
intellectually engaging
and you talk about that as something
that was also true of the people that
you were associating with so i get the
sense that there was some
sense of intellectual adventure and what
was it
what what did post-modernism mean to you
and why do you think
you were attracted to it what was
exciting about it
well it was a poetic sensibility it was
non-political in fact
um you know the the true materialist
marxists that
you know that were sort of in in our
in our uh social milieu they would they
would sort of scoff at us and say that
we were bourgeois
um oh that's what marxists do yeah right
so
you know we were just playing with
language and there really was no there
there and actually
what would what would deliver deliver us
from our current predicament was some
revolution in terms of material
circumstances and so um but i was really
you know
i was really drawn to the creativity of
reading a text
in a in a way it was i looked at it as a
way like i wasn't talented enough to be
a writer but i could critique something
in a creative way
and sort of get my get my revenge
in a sense like on the text right
because that's a hell of a way to that's
a hell of a way to put it when did you
figure out that that's what you were
doing
um i think i kind of knew it at the time
but later on reflection i felt when i
tried to be a writer
in my 30s and got nowhere
and became very frustrated and
despondent and depressed i thought
back at that time and i realized that a
lot of criticism itself is a kind of
the kind of criticism that we were doing
is a kind of shaking your fist
at the creative process and sort of
gaining
gaining power over over
art by by interpreting it in a way that
that
you found you know that that i found
you know fit my world and so it it is
you know what do you think the pleasure
and i mean you're you're you're making a
case for the pleasure in that you said
to some degree that you think it was
born out of
well it's something like frustration at
and i don't want to put words in your
mouth i i truly don't i'm trying to
extract out exactly what you're saying
and so if i'm wrong please correct me
you you had and perhaps this is not rare
among people who were studying
literature
at elite colleges i mean you you'd have
some
desire to think philosophically to be
seen as a philosophical thinker to be
seen as a creative writer to be a
creative writer
there's a romanticism about that and of
course
that ability is what the whole
enterprise depends on so it's sort of at
the apex but
you describe what you were
enthralled by at least to some degree as
revenge against not only the text but
against the creative process itself as
as a consequence of
of what what would the emotion be
because it would say like i didn't
i wanted to be creative but i just
couldn't you know i
i didn't feel like i had anything to say
and i felt that my
my authority was deeply compromised
just by my privilege or my place in the
world but i could actually i could reach
back into shakespeare and reinterpret
shakespeare in a way that
you know made me feel powerful
you know i could i could i could expose
the contradictions
think of of your of your peers and what
about your professors
you know i i think it was i think it i
mean i i don't know their state of mind
but i
i feel like a lot of what animated that
high post modernism it was you know
but it also had an element of
appreciation you know just like in the
way that marx admires capitalism it was
also
there was an element of you know wow
this is amazing but it's kind of
actually saying the opposite and and
this just dwelling in that
right you wouldn't be attending to it at
all if you weren't in some sense in awe
of it right because
why attend to that and not something
else so that has to be there at least
implicitly
so and and then you
after you you were finished with college
you said you you weren't sure exactly
what direction to go in and you tried
writing and
oh you also mentioned let's get back to
that a minute but you also mentioned
that
you discovered that you didn't have
anything to say and also you felt that
your authority was compromised okay so
those are two different things they're
worth delving into
it's not that surprising that you didn't
have anything to say in some sense
because i mean you were an undergraduate
and
what what do you know when you're an
undergraduate i mean there are
staggering geniuses that come along who
who who seem as an intrinsic part of
them to just overflow with
brilliant creativity but that's pretty
damn rare
and it's it's hard to have anything to
say when you haven't lived much yet
but then so so it sounds like you were
hard on yourself
because of that but also your authority
you said you thought it was compromised
what do you mean by that exactly
well even then i mean there was in my i
took some creative writing classes and
even then there was a conscience of
consciousness of identity politics and
that
the the real stories that would advance
society
would not come from a a white male
perspective
so i kind of bristled at that and but i
didn't feel like
the experience wasn't um of
what would you call interest it wasn't
of redemptive interest
right like i didn't have i had things to
say but
but you know the people people didn't
really
seem to value my perspective so i kind
of
swallowed what i had to say
i had a friend i wrote about him
extensively in my
not this last book i wrote but the
previous book and he was very guilty for
his
existence as um this is years ago as a
white male and
he virtually refused to participate in
society at all because
he had swallowed hook and sinker i
suppose the proposition that any
manifestation of ambition on his part
was to be viewed as part of the world
destroying force
now it eventually killed him there it
was complicated but that was certainly
uh a motivational
let's put it that way or
anti-motivational in a very profound way
so some of that was his own cynicism but
some of it was
a certain emotional sensitivity to the
potential impact his existence had on
oppressed others let's say at least
that's that's how he came to view it
so yeah i mean and i also had a lot of
rage in that you know i felt like i
when my friends were do we're organizing
things like or
you know greenpeace and so on i would be
kind of a
larping they would call it larping today
but i would i would say
you know well you just tell me when
you're ready to throw a bomb you know i
was obsessed with things like
you know a violent revolutions
i wanted you know i was i wanted to
learn how to hack
and freak with phones and you know
without without any real goal in mind
other than to
to to disrupt and break things
um and so i i guess you know i'm
actually lucky there wasn't an
antifa back then i probably would have
been a part of it and what
what do you think what do you think
attracted you to that
i'm very curious about this because
antifa for example i
i understand the attraction there's a
romantic attraction to
revolution you know i was i i had a
debate with slavo shizek
about hypothetically about marxism
although it didn't really go that way
but
when i was unpacking the communist
manifesto and
i mentioned that it was a call to bloody
violent revolution
and the crowd which was a very poorly
behaved crowd in many ways
broke out laughing and clapped which
which
really took me aback because i wasn't
promoting violent revolution in any
positive sense and i knew exactly or
know exactly where
those revolutionary sentiments got us in
the 20th century
but by the same token there is a
romantic attraction to rebellion right i
mean and
and it's linked to something very deep
which is the sense that we all have to
some degree that
we are um a minority of one against a
faceless bureaucratic tyrant
hell bent on at least shaping us into
this
into the form that it demands and
commands
and that that structure is to be viewed
even realistically with a certain degree
of skepticism and regarded at least to
some degree as an arbitrary tyrant and
and to stand up against that well that
there is something
intrinsically heroic about that although
it can go very
dreadfully wrong and it's something that
i mean young people are called to that
i mean the the developmental
psychologist jean piaget pointed out
that there's a messianic
stage of late adolescent development
where
not everyone hits it but a certain
number of people hit it and
that manifests itself in a
laudable perhaps concern with broader
issues in the world as part of identity
formation
that all supposed to be catalyzed and
shaped in universities
so it doesn't find channels that are
fundamentally destructive
psychologically and
socially so anyways back to you
so you were stymied to some degree in
your creative endeavor
and you found some outlet for that
frustration with post-modernism
but then there was also this this deeper
and darker attraction
to some degree that you just described
how have you made sense out of that in
the intervening years
um
i i think it really was a resentment at
not being able to be
creative in my own life not being able
to have
a generative healthy creative
life i mean a way to to deal with
certain impulses and channel them
productively
why do you think you believed that that
was the appropriate destiny for you to
begin with
well you know the great thing is that
you know i was able to
to work out issues with my father and
you know if you have problems with with
authority there's nothing
more attractive than i feel for myself
anyway
like is a moral a blank check
morally because then if you're if you're
doing things for the benefit of the
world well then you can
you can take out all kinds of debt you
can you can say well i'm
you know i'm i don't have to be a good
person because i believe in all the
right things and i can do
whatever i do is instrumental to the the
coming of a better world
so i you know i could i made my mother's
life miserable i would argue my father i
was you know i was
posing but i was inhabiting the pose so
deeply that i would be that i would give
myself some
you know i could justify anything by by
the fact that everyone else was wrong
and i was right
and you know i i found that as a as a
way to
to deal with things and i it was it's a
real high i mean it's a really
wonderful thrilling
um thing to inhabit
um even though you know now today i look
at it i look at it
very i'm very embarrassed by it um
but it's understandable i mean i don't
you know it could have been no no other
way
really why why do you think you
why aren't you like that now what
changed for you
well you know um i went through
uh i would say teaching teaching changed
me
a lot because teaching was a way for me
to to express myself creatively
and be engaged in the world in a regular
habitual productive way where i could
tangibly see the benefits of my efforts
and it was a social pro it's a social
thing teaching and it's a performative
thing teaching and it's very creative
and you know every day would be
different there would be new kids and
they would have different problems and
you know they would bring to me um you
know their own cultural reference points
so it's almost
it's just constant renewal teaching is
just a constantly renewing and
self-renewing
endeavor so i know you know i i realized
that with other jobs that were technical
or you know that were wrote
those became boring very you know within
three or four years but
after teaching for over you know six
seven years i was like this is this
still isn't boring i could do this
forever you know i love this
so you found a way to to contribute that
was concrete and habitual and regular
and
routine and that actually sufficed to
satiate your
creative impulse and that
removed your resentment would you say or
i would say it just it just kind of
um it tempered it
and and uh made me not worry about it so
much i
can't say it evaporated totally i mean i
still have an oppositional i guess i'm
an oppositional
guy in some sense but um as far as
institutions go but
um i i was able to just focus on
on my work and on the kids and and
trying to be good at what i do
and enjoying it you know and were you
teaching before you went back to
to hunter college or after no i had i
had um
i had been tutoring for a while before
that and you know i turned to
teaching when i you know the reason why
i actually got the degree in educational
psychology
it's a story in itself and that was one
where it was a jet
it was it was a desperate attempt to
avoid suicide essentially like i i was
so depressed
at that point in my life that um i
felt just compressed into this tiny
little ball and there was no
way out i was just you know how i got to
that point is all the thing but i
i just went on the internet and i was
like what is the last thing that i
remember
enjoying in my life when is the last
time i actually
felt a part of something and it was when
i was tutoring
um kids and and uh you know i had done
some light tutoring and i was like
okay that's really crucially important
so so because what you just said is you
know you were
you were in des in despair yeah and then
you were looking for something that was
genuinely redemptive and you were
searching your memory for that
and you found that in mentoring okay
why what was it about mentoring that
had enough value that it pulled you out
of that pit
or that you could see that as a pathway
out
it was just the experience that i
remembered of being with
someone and being able to give them
something that they could use
and having having that exchange be
rewarding
see i've been i've been very struck by
the
postmodern insistence that hierarchies
are predicated on
power and are to be viewed with contempt
as
as the manifestation of tyranny and as
self-serving selfish institutions and
i believe that that is true when the
hierarchies become corrupt but
what i've observed as the appropriate
counter position is that the people that
i've seen who i've admired the most
who are working diligently in
institutions
find the biggest pleasure in their life
in mentoring
and it's a profound pleasure there's
something about
allowing the best in you to serve the
best in others
that can't be beat by any other form of
reward
and a hierarchy that's functioning
properly i think has
the central aspect of a benevolent
father
which is something like encouragement
it's certainly not exploitation by power
and it's unbelievably cynical to make
the case that
that's the central aspect of functional
institutions having said that i
understand that institutions can become
corrupted by
tyranny and power and deceit but
i don't i do believe that the
the basis upon which a stable and
productive hierarchy
must be instituted is something like
the paternal care for the upcoming
generation
and i also believe that we do take the
most intense pleasure in that so it's
very fascinating for me to see that that
when you were scouring your memory and
and inhabiting a place that was quite
cynical and resentful that that turned
out to be the doorway that you could
path
pass through and and then you went to
you know you went back to university
and it was a consequence of your
experiences with tutoring
do you remember any particular episodes
when you were tutoring that stood out in
your mind
you know it's just sort of an image that
i have of being
with um you know with the with a young
person
and uh you know having having them
focused on what they're doing and
and me feeling connected to what they
were doing and just that
it wasn't even a specific image it was
just sort of a
you know something in my body that felt
good i mean and i really wasn't
thinking about it any more than that at
that point like it was just
it was literally just totally selfishly
when was the last time i felt any reward
in life
right well that's a that's a dead
serious empirical question
you know if you're if you're seeing a
good therapist if you're depressed
one of the things that therapist will
ask you to do is to
watch your life and see if there's
anything that lifts you out of your
miasma
and it's not a matter of thinking about
it exactly it's a matter of paying
attention
and it's often surprising you stumble
across something you think
oh that makes me happy or that
alleviates my misery and i really didn't
notice that before it wasn't part of my
theory you know it just happened to be a
fact that i was overlooking
it's dreadfully important to well it can
be life-saving as you
as you found out so okay so you went
back to
you went to uh hunter college and you
you
you you did an m.a an educational psych
what was that like
oh it was you know i i almost i almost
bailed out of the application process
well i you know
i i had i had chosen education in the
google search but then i
think well i got to pair it with
something else that i like so i just put
psychology down i was interested in
psychology and i
the first thing that popped up was
educational psychology degree
and i found like oh it's there's
something here it's a city college it's
i can get the degree and you know if i
spend ten thousand dollars which i saved
up for my previous job i could get this
thing
so i go i i almost fill out the
application
and then i kind of kind of get wobbly
and tell what's the point i'm not gonna
it's not gonna do anything
and then you know i remember calling my
mother my mother called me
and she you know they worried about me
because i was you know
really lost you know in my 30s and 40s
and
she said um you know you've got to go
through this you
you know she kind of got hysterical
because i think she just couldn't
couldn't handle like another
failed endeavor on my part or just
getting my act together
and i you know just to calm her down i i
went through with it
you know because just to sort of because
she was getting hysterical
and yeah well it's good to have people
around that will actually support your
attempts to
move forward especially when you're
fighting with yourself and
you know i've seen so many people
they're 51-49 about moving forward
you know or 49-51 and so they're not
doing it and someone else can come
behind them and give them a little tap
but
there are lots of people who don't have
that and so then they don't get that
little tap
and you know it wouldn't have taken much
to push them over the threshold so
yeah i was lucky um
so you know i got in i and then once i
started moving you know i would go to
i would go to classes i was tutoring on
the side and
and making money that way and i was able
to do that
and then you know i was going to class i
was making friends i was i remembered
how much fun school was
i was doing assignments and i was like
oh my god i mean i i just have to write
this paper
um life made sense again because it
brought back sort of all of the
the enjoyment of of undergraduate life
that i
really liked which is social and so it
really was just a momentum thing like
just getting back into it
um and then um
and what was the curriculum like at that
point oh it wasn't
um yeah it was it was a little bit uh
you know i guess educational psychology
it was uh more of a research focused
thing rather than
an education degree so we were
considered more
you know a science sort of a
science-oriented research thing
like you know um but and you know we
studied research methods
you know it was fairly rigorous uh you
know compared to
some education degree programs so we
didn't you know i didn't
we were sort of you know insulated from
a lot of the
the nutty stuff that was going right so
that's like an island too
in the same way stem fields are or
were somewhat of an island
so yeah okay so you came out of
hunter college and you were in better
shape i presume by that time
yep yep and then i applied to some
various teaching positions i teached
i i kind of made my bones uh
you know so to speak at some
different places like i worked at a
hague at a um
i think it's called the hagwon a korean
uh summer school
eight hours a day drilling s.a.t
um stuff um i worked at a at a failing
school
teaching you know tutoring s.a.t for a
while
or a ct and that was you know really
really heartbreaking because you know
those kids they hadn't had the same math
teacher
for longer than six months and they were
they were seniors and they
couldn't add fractions it was
heartbreaking
um and then i i applied to
grace church school it was a new school
that was starting up and they
i was able to sort of tell a little
story um
you know i had i had also published a
book out of high school
um called up your score the underground
guy did the sat with
with two friends and um
you know that was uh uh that was kind of
a fun little project and that that book
was still selling a little bit so i was
sort of able to piece together a kind of
out of my hodgepodge
life um make a little package and i did
a demo lesson and they liked me and then
i got hired
in the uh the inaugural faculty for the
for grace your school
and so what was it like going to teach
at grace
at grace church school well it was it
was really nice because
you know i was used to a corporate
environment i guess i
you know because of my time that i had
done in a previous job at hbo
um i was a technical manager it was a
whole other career
and you know i might i was i was very
concerned that i reported to the right
people
or you know what's the org structure you
know and they were just like well you
know just
you have colleagues and you can discuss
things with them and we're not going to
make you do anything
you can you can talk to us it was it's a
very friendly
um environment i mean there were serious
expectations
like you know and and everyone took
their jobs very seriously
but there really was a sense of
belonging
and community they were very it was
that was very welcoming actually and
very energizing i will say
because i wasn't used to that i didn't
expect it and so i would
be remain aloof from it you know at the
beginning like what's
where are these people why are they
always smiling at me like what's going
on
you know like i don't know why i just
but they gradually loosen up and you
you know it was kind of corny but i
would kind of go along with it and i i
it's a good kind of corny
yeah and i did actually you know i
warmed up a little bit i felt i did feel
like i was
a part of things and i was able to sort
of transmit that to others too
and so what happened over time
um it was a very gradual
change that you know i would say
well the within the first three years
one of the tenets of
our our school was that you
every employee and every faculty and
staff member had to attend a seminar
called
undoing racism
that was your hr department was it or
who yeah it was it was a
you know it was a mandate from the dean
of faculty at the time and the
it was a requirement yeah yeah and you
know
um so i went to that and that was a very
interesting
experience you know it's hard to um
what would you say refuse a call to
anti-racism
sure i mean what i mean what kind of
monster yeah
um and i you know you i went into it and
i
actually felt energized and i was
converted you know i had a sort of
you know i am white and i'm privileged
and you're right we need to
take care of this and there were people
in a circle and people of
all different races and backgrounds and
it was facilitated and
you know later i look back on it and i i
realized sort of how they
how they did it they did it in a very
interesting seductive way
um and what way was that well
you know as i recall they they started
out
um well it was sort of two parts the
first part was the history
since this you know the slave ships
landed on
american soil and then throughout time
leading up to the present and then they
focused for the second half of the
session they focused on
you know how to help a community that
has been shaped by all of this
and very early in the very early in the
session they said we want you to
withhold
any judgment of anyone's choice or
agency
anyone you know any of you know the
minority black populations that we're
talking about here
we we want you to simply bracket or put
you know hold
hold withhold any
analysis of the choices that people make
because you know
they that will often lead to a
misunderstanding or insensitivity
towards what's happening here so why do
you focus on that specifically that
issue specifically
well because you know it was as as they
retold the history and as they talk
about the present circumstances they
never
actually revisited that so you you know
you're you're constantly focused on the
oppressed population
in in terms of what is acting upon it
as far as acting upon those individuals
and you know to me that's like denying
a certain agency right and that but they
never actually lifted the blinders off
at the end like they
they would put these everyone sort of
acknowledged that they were gonna go
along with this
at the beginning and i was like really
we're going to do that we're going to
treat people as less than human
well okay i just it must be like a
temporary thing
and why did you see that as treating
them as less than human i mean
i presume that the people on the other
side of the fence would say well
you know we're we're we're all caught
like corks
on the sea in in the throes of vast
social movements over which we have
little or no control and
and who are you to cast judgment on
people who
have been the relative relatively
deprived in that regard compared to you
it's possible to make a fairly stringent
moral case that that's the appropriate
mode of behavior but
you were there was something in you that
objected to that
and you remember that now yeah
despite the fact that you said that you
were energized by this and pulled in by
it why do you think
why do you think it it caught you as
well
well it was a social thing right it was
it's a people in a circle and people are
talking about their experiences and
people are saying as a black person i
have
this has happened to me and at one point
they asked they actually you know and
they it's it's empathy right you you
care about people
you you feel if you're sitting face to
face with someone of course you're going
to be
i'm going to be sympathetic and
empathetic and and people are narrating
um you know but the problem i think is
generalizing that to
groups and you know getting you to make
a different set of assumptions about
those groups based on the sort of
you know selective way that the empathy
is leveraged
i would say well there's also the
implicit there's the implicit
what would you say the implicit
perceptual and categorical structure
that comes along with it which is
the a priory assumption that the
appropriate classification
for human beings is by group yeah
and and that that that's so implicit but
so pervasive that it
in some sense never needs to be stated
and as soon as you
assume that the group level is the
appropriate level
then you're bound to minimize or even
forbid
discussion of such things as individual
agency
so there's something if you believe in
individual agency
there's there's something yeah i mean i
guess about that
yeah yeah and i don't you know i
um i remember at one point they said you
know what
what do you like about being white that
was that was sort of a gotcha question
that they asked
the white people hmm
how did you answer that well i mean i'm
trying to think of how it's
some of these questions these questions
seem to come up in our society right now
that
that no one's ever asked you know like
well justify marriage
it's like well wait a sec i don't know
how to justify it we just sort of took
that for granted and maybe that was
appropriate
right right and so it's very hard when
you're put on the spot like that okay so
you're white what's so great about that
as far as you're concerned
well i kind of knew what that i kind of
knew what they were expecting so i kind
of tried to
play games with it a little bit because
i you know they
they what they were trying to do they're
trying to go through the embarrassment
of saying well
hi there's nothing special about me
being white there's nothing special but
i was
like no it's great i walk into a room
and everyone pays attention to me and
everyone thinks i'm an expert
and i said it because i knew that it's
kind of what they wanted
um but you know i
i don't usually feel that way but i knew
that's kind of what they wanted
but then i said it too like proudly and
then i made some other people upset like
some people like sounds like you really
really like being white and i said well
you know i i'm not
that's how i've been socialized and then
it was turned into kind of an argument
and then the facilitator had to defend
me
because i actually had told him what he
wanted to hear and uh it turned into
kind of a
a bit of a difficult moment um so i had
to
i had to say that that it was good to be
white
but not be too happy about it do you
think it's a
is it a reasonable question
i think the i think the unreason the
unreasonable part is more interesting
like it's reasonable if you take spoken
like a true postmodernist
if you take it if you take racial
identity
as well this gets into a whole identity
thing that i
i could talk about but please do okay so
so you know we know that race is a folk
taxonomy
okay it's not it has you know
groups and it correct me if i'm wrong
this is my understanding
you know i'm not an expert i'm a math
teacher so this is you can be sure that
no matter what you say you're wrong
i'm sure i'm wrong um yeah but take it
for what it's worth this
if you don't like it just stop watching
now um
you know as i understand from my races
of folks
taxonomy groups or individuals vary
more within the groups and between the
groups um it doesn't correspond in any
meaningful way to
you know i guess iq changes over time
and things it
it just doesn't have a lot it's a it's
it's not a
true thing it's not a true thing
so when people say you know you know
what do you like about being white
it requires resemblance category
and so a family resemblance category
it's a very strange sort of category so
imagine that
there's a category of 11 items and if
you have four of them you're in that
category
what that means is that two p two things
in that category can have two
different sets of four attributes and
still be in the same category
psychiatric diagnostic categories are
like that so maybe there's 11 symptoms
and if you have four you're in the
category so it's kind of
it's got edges like a like a a proper
set which are the
categories that we usually use in
science like triangles you can define
completely and you can tell what is and
what isn't a triangle
there aren't shades of triangle
essentially
and they're very distinguishable from
squares but family resemblance
categories we use a lot but they're
they're not scientific categories they
have their utility
uh and we use them a lot so okay so
anyways
back to race um so
you know there it's something that's not
true
and if you require someone to identify
with a lie
you are ins you are creating this sort
of fundamental distortion now i
understand that racism is
real that is it this lie is instantiated
in the world
and it's as a social construct people
is had tremendous effects on history
um but i have often wondered
what it is it's that obvious that racism
exactly is real because it's hard to
distinguish from in-group preference for
example
you know what i mean and and fear of
novelty for example and
it's complicated i'm not saying that
there's
obviously i'm not saying that racial
bias has never
existed but right you delve into it it
becomes extremely complicated
and it's very important if you look at
things like
the the hypothetical racism that the
implicit association test measures
it's by no means obvious that what it's
measuring is only well racism at all but
only racism because of all these other
issues and
it is different difficult we we tend to
uh be in favor of in-group favoritism in
certain situations and they're
ver and very violently opposed to it in
others so it's complicated
and murky but your fundamental point is
well
there's there's an insistence perhaps
that race is socially constructed and
arbitrary and yet it's the most
fundamental attribute that defines a
person
right and and that you know in our
school after we adopted a
curriculum um you know in sixth grade
um and maybe even earlier but i happen
to notice this in the curriculum
there is there is an exploration of
identity where
you know and i would actually really
like to hear your thoughts on this
you know the individual identity is sort
of acknowledged
right your interests you know
preferences dreams aspirations
personality character all of those
things are really important
and you are also have a social identity
and your social identity is how other
people see you and you're born into this
world where certain social identities
are valued more than others and so they
kind of
lead you outside the the house of your
self
understanding into this world of social
you know social impinging and
and gradually you sort of become
separate i think that
the effect of this is you should
prioritize how
other people see you when you when you
have a self-concept
before you even really know who you are
or you've been
you you really have developed yourself
you're supposed to sort of
i think the kids are supposed to sort of
hold it in abeyance and then
um prioritize you know how other people
view you and i don't think that's
healthy
what did you see the what did you see
the car what did you see as the
consequences of that in the school
i mean obviously this is starting to
bother you as this year you buy into it
to begin with
and and you're enthusiastic about it to
begin with and you attribute that to
well the mechanics of the initial uh
education let's say
um it's it's a it's a group phenomena it
capitalizes on empathy
it and it sounds benevolent certainly
in fact it's it's the very essence of
benevolence in some sense
so it's it's it's a it's going to be
seductive
regardless of whether or not it's
correct but you you become uncomfortable
with it
well the first thing you're
uncomfortable with is that
you were implicitly
asked to produce a falsehood in
relationship to your own identity which
was
yeah when you were asked the question
about what you liked about being white
and you said that what you said wasn't
right exactly or wasn't correct wasn't
true it was something that you whipped
up on the spot
because of the nature of the demand of
the situation and you remember that so
obviously that's significant
i think i was just meeting and what i
thought was an absurdity with an
absurdity
you know like i i felt the question was
a little bit absurd it's sort of like a
the premise right the premise is what do
you call it like
how how long have you been beating your
wife kind of question
you know so the premise of whiteness is
you're supposed you have to accept the
premise in order to answer the question
i really have never been comfortable
with the premise period because i don't
think that it
you know right it takes a lot of
presence it takes a lot of presence of
mind
when you're asked a question to question
the question
especially when you're the student and
it's the teacher that's
so to speak it's the authority figure
that's posing the question because you
immediately have to rebel and you have
to do it in an extremely sophisticated
way
yeah and you know this could get back to
the school and i might not have passed
the class and you know i'm
i'm white so that would have been
problematic and why are you
why and that would might have had job
repercussions or you know
promotions or whatever you know you just
you realize that
to question the question mandatory yeah
and to question the question
in these circumstances is you know the
the risk of that is so much greater than
the
the triumph of of dismantling the
question that you're just not you're
never gonna
and you may see you may even fail at
dismantling the way like your little
your little rebellion may lead nowhere
and you may be wrong
you know which is the hesitation that
anyone would have with an objection
just that you might be wrong and so of
course you're just going to fall on that
side of the equation i mean that's what
i did some people don't but that
would you know no most people do yeah
and no wonder
right it's hard not like you you
outlined a bunch of reasons why it's
difficult to you know come up with
exactly the right response at that
second it's not like it's a question
you're prepared for
right right and you know i think i think
the students do it all the time you know
because there's tremendous social cost
to challenging any of the
assumptions of our anti-racist
programming or the the
manner in which it's delivered what are
the costs for the students
um social
you know social appropriation
you could have you know teachers write
recommendations for them
if they get a reputation that there's a
fear that it could
affect their applications um
students have have come to me with you
know concerns and examples
of papers that they wrote say you know
on
taking a position that went against the
orthodoxy and they've you know suffered
a great hit from it and i've
i've asked him like are you sure it just
wasn't a good paper you know are you
sure and then like
no i actually cited this this and this
and i stood you know and so
i think um
i think they're real i think that
they're real and
there's actually been you know stories
that i've
that they've brought to me that are you
know
someone defends capitalism or something
and then they have a big talking to
after class or something like that which
is just
well yes i mean how could you possibly
defend capitalism while you're going to
a 55 000
a year private school right right um
i mean what's the probability that your
parents are capitalists
a hundred percent very high very so
basically you're
you're being you're being set to task
because you
have the goal to defend the very
attribute of your parents that enabled
you to go to the school in the first
place and that of course enabled the
school
right and it's so it's such an ironic
thing that both the administration and
most faculty
have such contempt for
the very thing that makes them have a
job
you know like they they believe that if
in order to achieve
why do you think they have contempt for
that given that it's the very thing that
allows them to have a job
i mean this is associated with the
question we discussed earlier right
about you being resentful back when you
were an
undergraduate it seems to me and i well
let me let you answer i won't i won't
push you yeah no i think that's a good
connection to make i mean
we all you know if you if you have
baked in a resentment of authority and
and and see all order is tyrannical well
then
you know even the hand that feeds you is
going to be
a tyrant and so it's also so convenient
you know i've watched among my
professorial peers i've worked with
business schools for example
quite frequently and i have my own
companies and did while i was a
professor and
i'm not an anti-capitalist and many of
my colleagues would
sneer at my involvement with the
business school
and i thought okay so what's going on
here it's like i know lots of
businessmen and
like look there's plenty of businessmen
who have contempt for academics so it's
not like it's a one-way street and
and i feel just as dubious about
the capitalists let's say the
entrepreneurs who
sneer at the ivory tower as i do about
the ivory tower inhabiters who sneer at
the capitalist but my sense always was
with something like well look i have an
iq of 145
and i'm not getting paid 700
an hour like my corporate counterpart on
bay street
and or wall street and i work just as
hard which is
true by the way because top rated
professors work
you know 60 70 80 hour weeks to keep on
top of their research just like the
high-end
lawyers do in in in corporate law
offices but they're not rewarded
financially to nearly the same degree
and so to me it was always just a matter
of straight out
envy it's like well if this society was
structured properly professors would
make a hell of a lot more than corporate
lawyers
it's like well yeah except you have
tenure and complete
creative freedom and you know that's
actually worth something
so and how dare you complain when you're
a tenured professor because you have the
best job in the world
so anyways so back to the
back to the faculty at the high school
yeah um you know i i think well
you know i this is not the case for all
of them and i really don't want to
generalize too much
but it does seem that in certain of the
humanities
subjects it tends to be more um
you know radical uh
questioning of you know the
the the foundations of
you know what what creates inequity in
the you know over
at these schools which are you know it's
almost like the more
the more opportunity these schools offer
the more they're part of a problem
i think is the view in the sense that
you know
it's if you're offering me some
opportunity right like if you're
offering
tuning into these elite kids well then
what about all the other
kids which is a good question um but
then you know
instead of sort of figuring out you know
the best ways to
to help the people that need it the
focus is on sort of
you know questioning and interrogating
the you know the the the site
of the top end of the inequality mm-hmm
well it's an interesting moral conundrum
right if you're working at an elite
private school
and your and your conscience is bothered
by inequality
and i mean virtually everybody's
conscience is bothered by inequality
there's very few people that walk down
the street and celebrate
tripping over a homeless person you know
that the typical person would rather set
the world up so that
people didn't fall out of the system in
such a painful manner
so you have that plaguing your
conscience but
it seems like and so maybe that does
provide a way out is
you can continue doing what you're doing
but you can also critique the system as
a whole and
regain some ethical equilibrium in that
manner
yeah i think that's a bit that's a lot
of it yeah for sure
um all right so you're initially uh
an advocate of this you're excited about
it but what happens yeah what as it
rolls out
over and so when did that start how many
years ago
about i kind of kicked in 2015 i believe
okay so it's about six years we're
talking about yeah and so
you know that the the word came down
there was a diversity
as i understand it this is you know um
pieced together but
there was a there's a diversity task
force on the board there was
there was a retreat a board retreat
that was led by something called the
carl
institute the carl institute
is this outfit one of these outfits that
uh that stands for critical analysis of
race and learning and education
and you know they you know influenced by
critical
theory i believe and then they you know
they
they sort of pitched their tent with
anti-racism as
uh as a philosophy and they started to
you know talk to the faculty a little
bit um you know
the what later became the office of
community engagement
or which is the sort of
the bureaucratic arm that you know is
essentially
a sort of ethical priesthood uh of how
to behave
properly in you know the school
environment and you know how to be a
good anti-racist
uh but they would ask they had meetings
but they would ask us things like well
what does anti-racism mean to you
and that's a perfectly innocuous
question and you know to me i was like
it means not being racist
it means not differentiating you know
individuals based on the color of their
skin and treating people with respect
and dignity no matter you know
what their what their skin color is and
and and they say well that's interesting
you know well you know that's very
interesting you know
okay well they and then they just heard
people out and some people had
more you know i guess i would say
advanced ideas
about you know being aware of systemic
oppression and
understanding different perspectives
based on how you might assume
a child had been you know had developed
given their circumstances
and those were rewarded you know much
more and those are not bad ideas you
know
we haven't we haven't got to the bad
stuff yet um
uh but it started to become apparent to
me i sort of had
the realization that this was really
going the wrong direction when we
we had a professional development
meeting and they they passed out the
you i'm sure you've seen it the pyramid
of racism
also known as the pyramid of white
supremacy and it
it had this a schema it was a schema
arranged in the form of a pyramid with
genocide
at the top of the pyramid and then
various layers that had
categorical names like overt racism
covert racism
minimization indifference
and then various there must have been
about 50 or 60 things sprinkled on the
pyramid at various levels
and some of the things on the pyramid um
i actually thought were
you know in many cases virtues uh
so things like um being apolitical
or things like you know um
you know there are two sides to every
story um
things that were contradictory like um
you know not believing poc
but also thinking well
my black friend said dot dot dot
so the idea that these two things were
next to each other
seemed interesting to me um also things
that were just
um you know political party plat you
know platforms
minimization yeah belong to the human
race right
right that was that was post-racial
society
why can't we all just get along
prioritizing intentions over impact
that's a nice one yeah yes we could we
could talk about that for about three
weeks
yeah not believing experiences of
people of color two sides to every story
right yeah well it's very interesting
when you look very carefully at the
words that are
lumped in with the other words let's say
right
by association okay so you had this
pyramid of white supremacy
and i was asked you know what do you how
do you respond to this what do you think
about this and i just
i said i think this is extremely
destructive and horrible schema to put
in front of a child
and i will never do it and i think that
it's
i just know and i said i went to the
office i said i'm not teaching this
and so this was when you were teaching
math well you know uh yeah i should
explain
it at our school all the teachers um
have other duties that are really
important like
you have an advisory and the
the advisor shepherds you know maybe
eight to ten kids through the
four years so they come to you with
problems and you can help them out you
can help them out academically
so this would have been something that i
would needed to share with
with the advisory and i think they
actually so you you registered your
objection i did this
this is the first time i kind of
registered my objection because i felt
why did you do that i mean look look
what you just told me
remember what you just told me you said
that at one point in your life you were
like dangerously lost and you found your
way out through mentoring
that put you into the education field
then you got a good job
that you liked with people you cared for
that was meaningful to you and it
structured your life
and then you bought into this
anti-racist uh
movement let's say and but now you
decide you're not going to do it
so like why you have a lot at stake at
this point
a lot so why what what's bugging you
about this
so much yeah i i think it i think
some things had happened before this
where i had spoken to
the head of school prior to this
and and warned him i i because i
immediately thought of i was just
thinking about
anti-racism anti-racism why does that
should be a good thing
why why does that bother me and i what
bothered me was that i knew that racism
was a concept that had
undergone an enormous creep that the
people had very different ideas
about what was and wasn't racist to some
of the american flag was racist
uh things that were you know
perhaps um innocuous to some would have
been considered racist to others and
then how would you
how would you adjudicate what you were
actually against and i saw this as a
real threat
because it would lead to real problems
in determining what it was that you
should be anti
and if you if you frame if you frame in
your mission
something which is anti something vague
you're really setting yourself up for a
witch hunt and i just sort of
especially look especially so we look at
this pyramid of white supremacy right
and at the top we have genocide
so it's like the ultimate evil
okay so that's what we're talking about
we're talking about the ultimate evil
okay so then you might say well maybe
your definitions matter when you're
talking about the ultimate evil and so
maybe being vague about exactly what
that evil is
especially if it's convenient for you to
be vague
perhaps that's a little bit ill-advised
perhaps particularly when you're
teaching children
yeah yeah um and
you know i i said well is this the is
this the comprehensive list of things
that belong on the pyramid are there
other things that we don't know that are
on the pyramid and they said well
you know there could be i said well
that's nice
so now we have other stuff that's just
in the margins that could be thrown onto
this pyramid
who knows what they'll be um maybe maybe
and who knows who will decide exactly
exactly like this is
okay so this list is not exhaustive um
and that actually scared me more
uh why well because it meant that
no one could anticipate where the lines
were i mean
kids need boundaries and so how are the
kids supposed to know what is and isn't
if they just have this grab bag of all
these possible things that could be
you know associated with the ultimate
evil
um you know that it just setting up this
whole tripwire
situation where they're just how are
they supposed to know how to trust
uh what is and isn't falling into the
schema that comes out of their mouth or
could they have a thought or that they
want to articulate it
how how you're just setting that you're
setting them up to for anxiety
and intention and you know
who it means that you're really
you know and i began to see this in
actual in actual
um discussions people have about it
peop kids were restricting themselves to
a very narrow
set of things to say that they felt
were okay to say you know and it was all
the jargon you know it was saying well
you know we need to acknowledge our
privilege yes we are privileged
you know that privilege makes makes us
unable to understand
okay so what you saw what you saw as
people's attempts to
deal with the ambiguity was that they
just stopped saying
anything that wasn't approved yeah
because that is the way out of it right
if if what's negative is ill-defined but
what's positive is listed then you just
stick with the list you stick with the
list
yeah you stick with the list um
and um
and then what's the problem with that
exactly so the kids stick with the list
why
why is that bothering you well it
it's it's because it means that
you know events the the multiplicity of
possible reasons for things that
that change that are different depending
on the actual incident
get reduced to this script of of
explanations
and only those explanations you know fit
the paradigm and only those explanations
will be considered
and and that means that you're not
making sense of the world for yourself
you're following a script
i don't think that's what you can do
okay so now you're you're watching this
it's having an impact on you it's having
an impact on
the students what's the impact on the
students personally too i felt
okay some of it was personal but also i
was seeing it
in the students um and particularly in
the
most recent years it
um
it's sort of like when you go to a
meeting and you know everybody is
the people there are people that are
silent and there are people that are
that are talking and the people that are
talking are saying all the right things
and the people that are silent are
listless and are disengaged
and just waiting for it to end and then
that listlessness and disengagement is
being framed as resistance
by the people who are running the
meeting they're the people that are in
charge of
delivering the anti-racist programming
and then there's there are meetings
about how to get
because that's indifference yeah and so
they actually call it pyramid of white
supremacy that in a pyramid every brick
depends on the ones below it for support
if the bricks at the bottom are removed
the whole structure comes tumbling down
which means that if you face down
indifference you eradicate genocide
right exactly and so it's it's a way to
use a structural metaphor
to transfer all of the like
all of the the weight of genocide onto
all the little things
um i'm not saying it very well but i
think you know what i mean um
so white so we would get we got an email
i remember getting an email
from the office of community engagement
that said we're looking for ways to
target
white white disengagement
and white was in brackets right it's
almost as little
we we're embarrassed to say it but it's
it's white
it's white disengagement right and
that's sort of like
we're going to say it but we don't
really want to say it
and that just made me a little bit even
more upset because it meant that if
you're not you're not even going to be
honest about what you're calling it
you're gonna try to
have it both ways um
so and what's happening among your
colleagues at this point you're you're
becoming dissatisfied
yeah what's the nature of your private
conversations are you starting to be
isolated
no i mean i i i i still getting along
well with
with the column with my colleagues and
you know there are there are
some that i have conversations with and
they'll you know they'll say well i
won't go as far as you but i
definitely think there's something not
so great about this
um you know i think it's you know the
other other
colleagues were concerned about the same
things i will i was i think free
expression and
the ability to entertain to have
different ideas and to talk about the
framework
and you know and maybe challenge it the
whole thing
um so yeah i was i wasn't alone in my
doubts for sure
did you ever wonder if it was you going
off the rails
sure sure i mean i i still
felt um
you know i still felt like it was
perhaps me
you know in the way that um
you know because i have had privilege in
my life i've had i've had substantial
privilege in my life
uh i would call it you know opportunity
and i'm grateful for it
one of the things that i learned about
studying the
aftermath of the russian revolution was
that privilege
creeps too because it's very very hard
to find someone who isn't privileged in
some manner
like the only person who isn't
privileged in some manner is the person
in the world who's suffering more than
anyone else
there's only one of him or her everyone
else is privileged
so you can expand the net of guilt
indefinitely by
focusing on privilege yeah yeah
and i didn't like the way that it was
being used to discount people's
people's ideas you know i mean if you're
if you're if you have an educational
institution
ideas are the whole are everything you
know and and the i
there should be you should be talking
about ideas based on what make ideas
sound or unsound not not the person
who's saying them
so oh i was seeing situations where
um you know white students would make a
claim and then that claim was discounted
by someone else because of their
privilege
you're making of course the white
supremacists assumption that there are
such
things as ideas and that they can be
ranked in terms of quality and that
the purpose of discursive speech is
precisely to do such things and
etcetera etcetera yeah and so the whole
solipsistic nature of it i was like this
is
you can't even have a conversation this
is not
this is not a way to have a functioning
you're not you're not preparing people
to function
in a truly virginia world of ideas it's
not well it's
it's worse in some sense is that the
claim fundamental claim is that there's
no such thing as a conversation
there's just different discourses of
power
there's no conversation assumes ideas
and the free flow of ideas and the
an irrational individual actor and the
capacity for logos and
and the individual as the central unit
and and so on and so forth
people who hold the critical race
position let's say
don't uh it's not that they avoid
confrontational conversations they don't
believe that there's such a thing as a
conversation
it's not part of the system so
it's a fundamental dispute yeah no
that's true i mean and i i
and then the little things like i
remember talking to a colleague
about a nuke about a new hire and then
and and she said um
i said well well what's he like
this new guy and she said well he's like
you
he's like me well what do you mean by
that and she was like oh he's white
i was like okay all right
you know this is not a person that's a
total stranger either and i kind of
walked away and like
really so okay
and you know i also i also hear the
objection to my
to my objection which is you know see
how it feels white man
see how it feels to be treated as your
race that is it's it's a
you know she might have been trying to
teach me a lesson in some sense
like now you know how it feels
but that's not you know okay that's
that's a point that you're making
but that's not that's not a healthy
thing and
that's not that's not good because it
doesn't actually
reduce the some type of misery in the
world yeah
i mean yeah um
all right so you're starting to get feel
disquiet and you actually make this
known
yes and i i make it known in 2019
i make it known in in 2020 i talk to the
assistant head i talk to the
head of school you're married i
i'm recently married i was i've been
married over a year just over a year do
you
do you have any children no children no
children but you are married and
okay so i'm just wondering what you have
resting on your job
exactly yeah yeah and i i didn't you
know i'm
i have to say that you know
not having kids is is is a huge part of
why
i feel like this is happening that i've
been able to
to stick my neck out um
and you know
i'm not not um i don't judge anyone for
for for balancing their duty to the
truth and their duty to their family
in whatever way that works for them
because both of them are important
um or to put things at risk
you know that's that's a personal choice
and that's
i can i can't speak to any of that but i
think it definitely
not having mouths to feed and
and you know having having some savings
from my previous job and
and things um being smart with
my money and not spending it um unwisely
as i have
as i had done a decade and a half ago
but um
i think that that helped me to do what
i'm doing
all right so how are you being treated
by the administrative
officials to whom you're registering
your objection are you doing that in
writing are you doing that
in person you know mostly in person and
you know i'm not
writing anything official i'm i'm in the
grumbling in my beard phase i guess i'm
in the griping phase
uh where i would go and i would say you
know this is wrong like why
can't we teach you know a broad range of
viewpoints why do we always have to
teach this
ritualistic thing that's just a litany
of
you know basically far-left ideas and
you know some of some some of the
administration were
very sympathetic like even overly so
like i remember talking to
um the assistant head he pulled down a
copy of jonathan hate off the
off the bookshelf and was like i'd love
to teach this in my class when i
i really want to make this happen i want
to teach you know so
you know more more than i was sort of or
maybe just modeling it or humoring me or
something
but he had the book he had the book
that's right and he knew the book and he
knew he knew where it was on his show i
know so like
but you know then in public you know or
in public in the in front of the
community
you're not saying nothing about it right
so i think there's a tremendous amount
of preference falsification
still going on there you know well you
outlined why
i mean yeah you lost your job
yeah so you know these are high stakes
games and
right you make a mistake and and a
mistake
you you veer outside the the realm of
acceptable behavior let's say and
what happens well you get
disproportionately punished for it and
there's a moral element
to it too which is well there's no
bloody way someone like you should be
teaching so
not only did we fire you but we're right
to do so
yeah so and you know that's very hard
thing to withstand which is something i
also want to talk to you about i mean
you know confident though you may be
or anyone may be when your institution
sheds you and surrounds that with
accusations about the nature of your
character if you're not a complete
psychopath it tends to strike you to
your heart
because there's always the possibility
that you're wrong right right
but i i really i really knew i wasn't
because
you know coming out there was this
meeting and i referred to it in the
article
or my essay the self-care through an
anti-bias lens meeting
which is what kicked off the whole um
past two months for me it was a
it was a meeting where students were
ostensibly going
to learn how to take care of themselves
during the pandemic
how to manage their emotions
how to take deep breaths and cope with
things
and in that meaning you know after some
some mind
relaxing exercises like meditation and
and stuff they put up the white
supremacy you know
aspects of white supremacy culture slide
and that's different than the pyramid or
this is different than the pyramid
and this is you know this is elements of
white supremacy right
right it's actually um you know they
there's different forms of it
but essentially you know it's
it's fairly common in this in this thing
as you know and um
uh
yes so here's some professional and
transactional relationships
versus relationships based on trust care
and shared commitments
protecting power versus sharing power
culture of over
working versus culture of self-care and
community care
competition and struggle for limited
resources versus
collaboration and working to share
resources that's all
white dominant culture so yes yes and so
some of the things that were on this
particular slide
were objectivity individualism
um either or thinking right
right and uh i know that one
there was um you know the the thing that
wrangled me the most was
right to comfort because
you know how how are you giving a
self-care
workshop where the 200 kids that are in
there
in this racially segregated workshop
are challenged that they might not you
know that having
imagining that you have a right to
comfort is associated with
you know genocidal evil kenneth jones
and teema oaken dismantling racism
workbook
2001. god only knows what that is but
it's everywhere
the characteristics of white supremacy
culture perfectionism
which is an element of conscientiousness
which is a fundamental trait
sense of urgency defensiveness quantity
over quality
worship of the written word paternalism
either or thinking
notice this is all written in words by
the way power hoarding fear of open
conflict
um individualism which seems to be run
somewhat counter to the fear of open
conflict progress is bigger and more
objectivity right to comfort yeah it's
uh it's quite the grab bag of
conceptually unrelated items it's
incoherent at every possible level of
analysis
as well as being it's it's impossible to
parody
yeah yeah and i i saw it and i
you know i had been thinking for a
couple months prior to this because
there had been some meetings that really
upset me
and i was thinking well and my head of
school had actually said that if i was
in an appropriate forum
i should feel free to ask questions by
this point in the meeting
i think maybe 30 minutes in before this
popped up other faculty had been
saying things in the chat area of the
zoo meeting
so you know is that anonymous is that
anonymous in the zoo
no it's it's they were so they were
under their own names
under their own names yeah um and so i
thought well why
you know when the when the facilitator
mentioned
that if you looked at this slide i think
she said
i think she said you know you might have
some white feelings
um and i said i just kind of
blurted out i didn't i didn't blurt it
out angrily i didn't flirt it out
i i don't think i was too upset of
course you know i
i don't know how it was perceived of
course but i said well what do you mean
but what is a white feeling what is the
white feeling
and i you know what came back was i
think she said something that
defensiveness was a white feeling i said
well these
feelings can belong to people of any
race and you know i think that it's
i i don't know whether it's i don't
understand why it's being attributed to
a particular
the white people um
and you know i had that kind of opened
the gates a little bit and kind of broke
the ice i think because in the chat
other kids started to ask questions
there was a debate about whether i
should be allowed to ask the question
um there was which question do you mean
the question about the white feeling
question i see there were also some
there was a lot of capitalism bashing in
the chat and i said you know i believe
capitalism is anti-racist
since it's done more to to lift
people of all races out of poverty um
than any any alternative
um and you know i wasn't monopolizing
the chat i was
dropping in little things and there was
a lot of activity in the chat
and then um the the
the facilitator actually went with me
and she she explained stuff
you know her perspective on it and i
thanked her and you know
she moved on some more and um
i think i i asked another question but i
really as as she said later in a meeting
about the meeting
in front of the whole faculty she felt
that i
you know i was asking out of curiosity
didn't i wasn't
you know on a rant or saying it you know
to to be
antagonistic i think some of the some of
my faculty members felt that i was but
the facilitator herself didn't
feel that way so and she was the one i
was talking to so i think that
definitely counts
that's quite remarkable i would say
because it's very difficult in a group
like
that when you know the implicit ethos
to be able to say something that's
questioning
without having anger build up as a
motivation right because you need
something to break through your
resistance
yeah so yeah to be able to say it
without upsetting the
the uh yeah i mean i was passionate but
i wasn't i don't think i was like
enraged or anything like that um it's
you know i was trying to modulate what i
was really upset was that
was the either or thing because i was
like well if either or
thinking is a is a characteristic of
white supremacy well then ibram candy's
got to be the whitest
person in public life because his entire
philosophy is so
manichaean i mean anyway
so but i didn't say that of course
because i would have been inflammatory
but
um what i really wanted to do i've been
thinking about an opportunity because i
wanted to model for the
students that you could ask questions
that someone who
who was a teacher or someone who was an
authority figure could ask a question
and it was okay
and and did and how did the students
react to
it was it was phenomenal i mean i was
really gratified and that they confirmed
that
my it confirmed that i was doing the
right thing because
things came out in the chat they started
to ask a broader range of questions i
received the
transcript later and you know it was
like night and day kids were asking
questions like well i don't feel like
i'm ignorant just because i'm white
or you know i don't like to be reduced
to my race and then faculty joined in so
several faculty members also
started to ask questions um you know and
i don't think the point was that they
people they if people even necessarily
wanted their questions
answered in the forum they just wanted
to ask them
i got you sometimes i don't know what
your question is until you ask
exactly like this this that's why i
think intent is so
it's kind of a silly thing because you
never really
it's only an ex post-facto explanation
if you're called on it i think like a
true question there may be no intent
like it just bubbles out of you if
you're if you're truly in a
in a conversation i'm not thinking about
okay i'm not it's not like i'm plucking
this little thing out of the inside of
my head and
like well i intend this to be you know
that's not communication that's
not if it's a genuine conversation no
you don't have time for that in a
genuine conversation no yeah of course
not and so
you know but i was really gratified
i was on a natural high from the
experience
um why well because i felt that i had
you know i had done something
good like it was just self-evidently
good to me like it
just when i reflected on it this is a
positive thing
um now one of the my colleagues got very
upset with me
with my influence on this and because at
one point i did say
you know why you know i don't identify
as white
must i internalize society's
delusions about me um which is
you know like it's kind of like the
neutron bomb
to this entire belief system but i was
on
i was on a you know i felt like it was
something i wanted to put out there
so the kids could see it and you know
understand
you know that maybe this is a point of
view you know i'm not saying i'm
right i'm i'm asking a question um
and you know the the feeling was that
this was you know anti-racism
some defense yeah like i could just
i'm not morally obligated to accept
these characterizations
right which is kind of the whole point
of anti-racism is that you're not
obligated to
accept arbitrary racial categories that
are unrelated to the task at hand
yeah well it should be um
but uh you know then a colleague got
upset with me
and said kind of got on his high horse
and said
you know i can't believe that i may be
mis
you know paraphrasing here and if i am
sorry but he said
i believe you know i can't believe that
a member of our you know
our one of my colleagues doesn't
understand that we are white
that we are white since birth i am white
since birth that this has carries with
it implicit biases that
are unavoidable and we must affirm that
you know and and that's who that's who
we are and that's who i am and i just it
kind of interrupted him because i felt
like he was
kind of making me look
i know he's being kind of kind of a jerk
so i interrupted him and said
you know i'm sorry you're stereotyping
yourself i think it's sad
[Music]
and you know that kind of was a very
awkward moment
because it was in front of students and
he said
you know he expressed his dismay um
and i remained silent and then after the
meeting i said
i apologized to him i said you know that
was unprofessional
was it well you know i i unders i felt
it i felt that there might have been a
better way that i could do it
maybe wait till he finished and then
asked you know to respond
i i i'm i'm also suspicious of my own
you know because i i i have been
somewhat oppositional i'm not exactly
like a mr go on and get along guy with
this stuff that
i don't always have the best reality
check on my own behavior
and so i'm you know i i was just
saying well okay if i if i did cause
offense then you know i i feel like it's
okay to apologize and there probably was
a better way for me to do this
and so i did apologize and you know and
thought about it
no nothing against that nothing wrong
with that and then he accepted
and you know i figured that was that was
it and there was a lot of processing
after the meeting i think
that went on for hours afterwards my
phone died it was on my phone and so
when i went home
um you know i logged back into the
meeting and people were still there
talking
so i talked to them but i underestimated
the effect of this because apparently
um some of my some of my comments you
know were leaked
or made or transmitted to other people
that weren't in the meetings
people that were in the the bipark
meeting you know
particularly my mice bypark
is a black and indigenous people of
color so they were having their separate
meeting
of faculty and students where they
received different content
and why was it separate
the rationale as i could as i can
understand it is so that
the groups that have been marginalized
won't be exposed to
you know they'll have their own thing so
that they're not exposed to the
uh i think the incense possible
insensitivity
of the
[Music]
oppressors that's the best i can
understand the rationale
um but it wound up happening anyway
because
i suppose it would be rude of me to
point out that that's somewhat
paternalistic
you know just as yeah you know
observation that's a good one
um yeah i mean yeah totally well
i guess that is a characteristic of
white supremacy culture though
paternalism yeah so
and i guess it's well as long as it's in
a good cause then i guess it's
forgivable
yeah okay so that was how long ago that
meeting
that was february 24th oh yes okay so
things are starting to
yeah this year and that was referred to
after the fact as the events of
wednesday like they couldn't even really
it was sort of like 9 11 they couldn't
actually they had to come up with a
euphemism for it i guess um
so the events of wednesday and so they
had meetings about
the events well the office of community
engagement
it coupled with the dean of student life
and there
there are dean level positions
that exerted a lot of effort and energy
because i did not make their lives easy
um to to address
the things that were said and raised in
the meeting not just by me but by
you know lots of different people and
students
students you know spoke up as well and
faculty and so
um what i found it so interesting
because the day after the meeting
there was an email that was released
that said healing resources
you know healing resources that will
help
you come to terms with what happened and
the first healing resource
on the list was a cnn interview
with a poet named damon young
and damon young
you know in this interview said things
like
you know we we need to get rid of all of
capitalism
we will have to do a carpet bombing not
a carpet cleansing
of society i mean it was incredibly
radical statements that
were i would imagine would be
frightening to to many people
and that was listed as a healing
resource as well as well as long as the
carpet bombing only targets the
malevolent people
well yeah i guess and then things there
was a robin d'angelo article
that said you know what white people
need to be made or kept
uncomfortable um how can we become more
uncomfortable
um also you know really kind of
i would just say racist
characterizations of white people
in these links um things like you know
white people
have never had to be guests in this
country and
like the irish for example they weren't
really white to begin with though so
yeah yeah um and so
i found this very ironic and then i had
a series i had two meetings i had a
meeting with my
head of high school and the assistant
head
and i had a meeting with the head of the
whole school
and then you know i the head of the
meeting with
the head of high school they called you
in
at that point yeah i mean what's
happening around you is this is growing
this is this well yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of agitation there's
meetings about meetings there's
student diversity council meetings um
there are um there's just a lot of
agitation in the community i would say
uh and and meetings about meetings so
some of the things that would happen
would be in the week
in the end as the week continued there
was a faculty meeting about it
um i had some advisory circles
circle practice was taken away because
they felt that it would be
the students would be upset if i was a
part of it
so the d so the environment circle is
what um well it was it's a
it's a practice that we've started this
year
where um activities
um where you you put up a slide and you
talk about an issue and then everyone
has to go around and speak
one by one about a question and then you
kind of do it around twice
and then you know this is to sort of
manage discussion
um and i've done so you're not you're
persona non grata at this now because
yeah
what your toxic influence on the
students right right
and so you know i got an email saying
you know under current circumstances
following yesterday's meeting in your
role and what transpired
you you know i've asked you to recuse
yourself
um then you know
there were subsequent meetings there was
a faculty meeting
i think at that faculty meeting a
colleague said well this is
this could be terrible this could undo
everything we've ever taught them
which i thought to myself please please
i hope so um but uh
the uh and there was
how are you how are you reacting to all
this well i'm on a natural high i mean i
i know that i feel like this is
something that i finally done
to to open up something
like some daylight and i
all of this churn is going on around me
but i'm going about my day i'm i'm
teaching my classes uh
i'm you know i
i did feel the need to address my
classes so i said
at the beginning you know i am an
anti-racist
um you know i want you to feel safe and
then i would just sort of teach the
class
and then i was told not to address it
with the class with anyone
in the classes i had written i had sort
of had a sort of i guess a manic kind of
outbreak at this point like i felt so
much energy
and and enthusiasm that i was writing in
my notebook a lot
and i developed a kind of
i had a sort of creative outpouring
through all of this
um i don't know whether it's maybe like
a psychothemic
reaction or something to it because i
felt like my soul
was kind of awakened no i was having a
lot of trouble sleeping i was you know
maybe getting three hours a night and i
would wake up
i would wake up at like four in the
morning just being like
wide awake and i'd go and i'd start
writing and i'd write a lot of ideas
down
and i felt like it was really productive
and what do you think of the ideas that
you were producing during that time
um i've this type of thing has happened
before
and i've i've looked at them with later
eyes and i don't think that i i've kind
of felt the despair that they weren't
um that there wasn't much value to them
but this time well
one thing i might point out is that you
know writing
writing is overproduction followed by
culling
right and so you'll have periods of
overproduction and you probably throw 90
of that away but
maybe you keep 10 and that's a lot more
than zero
yeah yeah i mean mostly what i was doing
was illustrating a kind of geometry
like i had i had a these two axes
and i was sort of laying things out on
them because i was trying to make sense
of
of the whole problem of of racism
and um the difference between reality
and truth
and how those things are kind of
orthogonal
and i kind of laid out a schema that
made sense to me that would that was
kind of explaining the whole problem
and you know it still does make sense to
me and i still
think that there's a tremendous value in
it and i just need to
want to keep working on it um but
yeah well it's common that those those
those periods of
of creativity you know they're they're
revelatory thinking and
that can be over emotional and yeah it's
so so tangential
but but it's it's gripped for further
milling
yeah yeah and it did crisp crisp over
the wrist
yeah grist great crisp bristle
um so i all of this was happening around
me but i felt like a kind of stoic
indifference to it because i
i felt a sort of awakening in me that
that
that made ever all of the hubbub
uh sort of irrelevant you know it sounds
like you had decided to do this
yeah i think i i think i had been
waiting
sort of unconsciously waiting for an
opportunity and when it happened when i
blurted things out and it
it happened then i embraced it and i
realized that i had
i was not ashamed and i was not
controlling
and i was proud i was actually proud
and when so now and then when did you
write the essay that that
that was oh yeah with barry weiss i
don't want to rush you if there's
okay yeah and i hate to hear it i i
realize that
you know i don't want to you know tax
you either
but um
i had um
i knew i wanted to write about the whole
thing so i i
i had taken a lot of notes over the
years and so my first draft
was about 5 000 words and it contained a
lot of
information centered around the actual
zoo meeting and then
you know the effects on the students
and you know what had happened to me and
then i realized like what
the reason why i did why i said the
thing in the meeting in the first place
was because i was
trying to model for the students and
that was what was animating me
and so i i'd you know i i handed it off
to
a friend who edited it and really hacked
it way down
you know cut out a lot of the stuff and
then i did another draft
where i was really trying to get to the
main ideas and boil them down as crisply
as i could
and then barry took a look at it and and
how she made it
through the fair through fair because i
had been volunteering with them
um for a couple of months now and fair
just so everyone knows
is is a foundation against intolerance
and racism
and you know we you know i was in the
process of
i i still am you know helping to
build the organization and and select
chapter leadership in
in various states so that we can really
we're in this sort of
networking phase because i'm calling
people have given us their names and i'm
calling people
and and what i'm finding is that
everyone has a story
so i can't just be on the phone with
them for you know 15 minutes and all the
volunteers are finding this that there's
a tremendous outpouring
it's very emotional they'll talk about
what's happening with their kids
they'll talk about that they didn't
suspect that anything was wrong in the
culture until maybe a year ago and now
it's
clear to them and they want to do
something and so you
really have to do you have to listen
before you can you know just
operationally try to plug people in and
you know
a lot of times it's it's it really feels
like i'm not a therapist but it feels
like
at the peak i was making like five calls
a day and each of those were about an
hour
and you you wind up really having
having an engagement with another human
being so this is starting to inform your
writing
yeah and the way you're thinking about
what's going on at the school
yeah and so um i'm sorry i'm starting to
feel like
i have a lot of people that i'm
you know that are that this is something
that's becoming kind of a duty
like almost a moral duty uh
so um yeah so that's kind of the
the background to that and then
and then the article came out and um
i i waited and there's just a tremendous
i've had an email at the bottom of the
article and
i was expecting like 50 positive 50
negative i would be happy if it was 50
positive now i realize later it's on
barry weiss's sub stack and it's mostly
her fans but
i put the email on some other places and
uh
and i was just amazed that you know
maybe 500 emails in the first two days
and and long emails like me people
writing you know some of them are just a
word or
a subject line but people had a lot to
say a lot of stories
and i've spent um a couple hours each
day
since then going through them and
responding to everyone because
it's really important to do that i think
that
you know i feel i feel like it's just i
can't just
you know ignore them or just give like a
one sentence thing because
some of these some of these uh
i try to you know i try to respond in at
least one or two sentences in a way that
addresses
their particular situation and then i
and they try to direct them to fairs
as you know as an organization that can
help
and all people of all different
backgrounds
people wrote in from other countries and
what are they telling you in the main
they're just a lot of what i'm getting
i'm just getting a lot of pats on the
back
just like yes you know good for you
bravo like you know this is amazing keep
doing it keep
doing what you're doing we support you
you know 100
this is a huge problem you know and
you're standing up for it and
what you're doing is right and
you know and and uh
okay so you publish this in barry
weiss's sub stack
and the school reacts
and what happens well they make the
claim that
um um that i've you know some of what
i've written is
is a mischaracterization
and uh
you know they're not trying to you know
they they i think
it's a little blurry to me now actually
because so much has happened since so i
kind of have to
reconstruct what happened but um
uh in this time so the article came down
on the
i believe on the 13th
and um you know i had a contract
assigned for the following year
and part of that contract my contract is
up
this current contract is up at the end
of august but the deadline for me to
sign
next year's contract was april 15th
and as one of the stipulations of my
contract was that i had to attend
restorative justice practices designed
by the school
to address the harm that i had caused
students of color
and other students i see so you were
obliged to be guilty enough to go to be
retrained
right and you know the details of the of
this process would be revealed to me
after i signed
so i was signing something that i didn't
you know i
wouldn't know what i was signing so i
waited
from an admission of culpability and
guilt right
right unspecified nature right and now
participation
i thought about i was like well
participation doesn't mean
that i have to you know say me a copa i
can participate in it
um maybe it's an opportunity for me to
engage you know
um and i thought about it but then i
said well it would mean that i was
signing on to it mean that i was
legitimizing it by signing it and so i
decided not to sign it
because if i if i put my word on it then
it would mean that i was
saying that that was an appropriate
request to make of someone
so i didn't say how did you manage to
make that decision
well i just really just delayed it and
thought about it
and then i talked to friends about it
and then i i realized that no i'm just
gonna
i'm just gonna let it lapse because
you know i'm i'm uh i've reinvented
myself before
i've had several careers i i have math
skills
coding skills i figured you know if i
didn't work for grace
i could find i could land on my feet
somehow i didn't i
don't have kids so there there were i
had i felt like i had
options you know i felt like no matter
what happened
i i had faith that i would be okay
um so i you know i felt like i could
kind of decide whether
this was this was right for me or not
and i could teach somewhere else maybe
not
you know in new york maybe i could find
like a
private boarding school or something
that was more aligned with my views or
my values have the offers come flooding
in
yeah i mean since the article uh you
know
places in coral gables was like come to
coral gables we'll give you you know
we'll
we need someone for our math program
texas arizona
and surprised to hear that yeah and you
know i
my fears of being canceled are
completely
obvi you know blown away because
you know that it's the opposite of that
i would say um no i'm sure i'm sure
there are people that wouldn't touch me
with a 10-foot pole
but do i want to work for them i mean
it's sort of like a self-selecting thing
now you know
i did this thing the world has sorted
itself out
there are people that would hire me um
and so those are the people that i will
that i could work with and then
what do i need to why do i need to worry
about people who don't want me
you know it's kind of like all right
so and also you have to
move forward on false pretenses yeah
yeah
and um but i think my
my main gratitude that i feel
is that
uh is that i made you know i made my dad
proud
and uh and my mother is not with me not
with
us anymore but she would have been proud
of him why did it matter to you
well you know he's a i consider him to
be very important
person and uh
he taught me so much he taught me how to
write he taught me how to think
he's uh he's a law professor he was
until he retired recently
and um he was a great he was a real
teacher he wasn't a
he wasn't so much of a publisher he was
a teacher
and he was very popular um very talented
uh and he would always engage me in
socratic discourse and he always wanted
me to think for myself
and um you know i did
i do feel like i've probably been a
disappointment
more than once to put it to put it
mildly over the years
and so having the opportunity you know
he's 88
having this chance to sort of
do this thing now maybe just one act
maybe i'll i won't write anything ever
again but at least i've done this thing
um and talking to him about it and
it's uh it's a good feeling
now the school has stopped you from
teaching apart from the fact that you've
not signed the upcoming contract right
they had they offered me
um they offered me something i thought
was kind of creative they offered me
the chance to participate in a
subcommittee of the institutional
culture committee
um which is a committee that's centered
around designing an anti-racist culture
for the school
now i would work under the direct
supervision of the supervision of the
assistant head
but it would they would they wouldn't
let me teach math they wouldn't let me
have an advisory they would take away
all my teaching duties and that's
basically what i would do for the next
um
july you know the next five months until
my contract expires
um so i thought of that i
i think that what it really is is just a
way to co-opt me
and to sort of put me in a kind of
rubber room i mean i don't have any
confidence whatsoever that any of my
you know any of my um suggestions or
contributions would be taken seriously
um which would involve
like complete upending of the entire
program
um to account for free expression and
viewpoint diversity
and you know diff completely different
epistemology
um i don't feel that they're going to
take that seriously and so if you know
i'm not sure if my
my continued um employment you know i i
don't think that's what were the grounds
for
stopping you from teaching
how was that framed exactly yeah that
was an interesting thing so i received a
threat
from a member of the community it wasn't
a physical threat it was a menacing
threat that was centered around my
my employment my livelihood you know it
said a lot of
things like don't dare come back to the
school your life is going to change
your future is you know you're going to
be canceled you're
you're never going to be able to work
anywhere you know the
this we will see to it that you're it
was it was a menacing email so i
reported this email to the school
and um you know the school got back to
me or
the head of school got back to me and
said well you know if you don't feel
safe
as you don't feel safe um
we don't ask that we we you might we
think it's a good idea if you stayed
home
and taught remotely oh you know only
over zoom and don't come on to the
school grounds
and i wrote back to them and i said well
actually i do feel safe
i want to come to school i like to teach
in person
um and you know i i expect i was simply
bringing this to your attention
so that you could take care of this
problem um
and then they wrote back saying well as
you know
we will be polling the students and and
community members to find out whether
this opinion is shared by other people
so they treated this menacing email as
an opinion
and and they said you know subsequent to
that they said well
since the school you know community
feels that
they can't participate in your classes
because they were probably objecting to
your right to comfort
yeah probably you know and i said things
like well i fully expect you to maintain
order
and security in the school i mean that's
that's something that you should
and i find it rather odd that if if you
know
someone who sent a a menacing email to
me should not have to stay home but i
should have to stay home
what is the why am i the one that has to
stay home why
why isn't this other person staying home
so but they didn't have much sympathy
for that point of view
so rather it was this this threat was
taken
as a kind of um
you know example of people's feelings
of of insec unsafeness around me
so i was i was asked to say right you
provoked them to that
right right exactly um
now you also exchanged an opinion or two
publicly with the if i've got this right
with the headmaster you
said that in the conversation he had
indicated his agreement with your
proposition
that's right white people but children
in your formulation to begin with
were being demonized by the curriculum
and
through you made that claim and he said
that was not true
and then you released the audio which i
reviewed and which seems to clearly
indicate that he did in fact say
exactly what you said he said that's
right that's right
let me ask you something george because
i think those are i think there's
something very different
about having a single experience where
you
make sense of it right and having a
teacher an authority figure
talk to you endlessly every year
telling you that because you have
whiteness
you are associated with evils all these
different evils these are
moral evils it's not the same as taking
like a physical thing
because it doesn't affect your your your
moral value
that's the problem the the
the fact is that i'm agreeing with you
that there has been a demonization that
we need
to get our hands around in the way in
which people are doing this
understanding okay so you agree that
we're demonizing kids we're demonizing
um kid we're demonizing white people
for being born and are some of our
students white people
what are some of our students white
people yes
okay so we're demonizing white we're
demonizing white kids
why don't you just say it we are right
we are using language that makes them
feel
less than um for nothing that they are
personally responsible for any doubt
because i've known you for nine years of
your sincerity
in your belief and
i also um
have grave doubts about some of the
doctrinaire stuff that gets spouted at
us in the name of any races
like what and and so i
don't disagree entirely with some of
your points of view
can you elaborate because that would
help me it would help me understand
like what's going on i think
that one of the things that's going on a
little too much
and we've talked about this is that
um the demonization of being white
um and in the attempt to link anybody
who's white
to the perpetuation of white supremacy
thank you thank you george
so there is no question that there is an
entire strain in here
that um causes that misinterpretation
now
i am somewhat wait a minute but what
about impact over intent
don't those kids get the benefit of
impact over intent
our attempt is going to be to get
everybody centered again
all right um i will tell you i mean
that's a huge task because i will tell
you that we are
if you if you try to do that
um
they're they're already like the barn
doors open and they're all in the barn
i mean they're gonna they're gonna
they're fighting a revolution that you
you don't even know they're fighting
and grace they're gonna hollow out grace
and they're gonna move on to the next
institution
that's what's gonna happen like i i
think that
they've hollowed out a bunch of other
ones ahead of us so yeah that's what i'm
saying you're just you're just a little
stoned in the path
this beautiful wonderful institution
that's educated so many
children over so over almost a century
is what was the consequences for him
of of that well i have no idea because i
haven't heard anything
in the in the two days since the audio
has been released at this point
so he's been still employed as far as
you know
as far as i know yes i don't know what's
happening there um
i'm i'm not privy to i mean i still have
email
my email account is still active but i
don't
you know i i haven't seen any
communications about anything so
um i don't know
his situation there hasn't been any
statement from the school
at this point okay so a couple of things
that we should cover before we stop
um what do you what are your feelings
about
the importance of what is transpiring
around you
to broader let's say educational society
let's let's start with that with
with with regard to teachers and
students
in private and public institutions high
schools junior highs elementary schools
in your state and across your country
what
what do you see this if anything what
does this indicate
well i have hopes you know i i feel that
if if students can if i if
if the type of
you know willingness to ask a question
it in response to some of these
you know what i consider to be
indoctrination frankly
at other schools and you think that's
happening in other schools
yeah i mean i it's no question because
of the the calls that i've
received in the conversations i've had
with people all over
pennsylvania virginia maryland new
jersey you know their
their parents are very concerned with
their children they've seen it
because of the pandemic through their
through the zoom
zoom classes they've witnessed what's
being taught
to their kids and they're very very
concerned
and they have specific receipts to back
it up
and you know they're sending me
curriculum
um so you know i i have this is not
simply a a rarified
independent school problem this is
happening at you know school boards and
districts all over the country
um a lot of it spurred by the you know
the george floyd
it's killing and the reaction to it um i
believe it was taken as an opportunity
to
you know redress um
that with uh misguided yeah an
opportunity for what
it's like i'm trying to figure out i
keep trying to figure out because i've
been concerned about this for
a long time and uh
i still can't get to the bottom of it
it's like i don't understand
exactly i know there's a resentment
element to it but i can't understand
exactly what's driving this
and and why it's despite the fact that
it's
clearly the view of a very small
minority of people
perhaps five percent that's what the
survey seemed to indicate
i cannot understand why it's making the
headway that it's making at the rate
that it's making
and what it's really aiming at
what do you think about that like what's
your sense
because obviously it's bothering you
yeah
i think i have a sense why and maybe
it's a theory
it's not just my theory but it's i've
seen it in other places or hinted at in
other places
i think when you sort of you know over
the past
few decades you have a gradual
sort of leeching from the soil of
society of sort of a
moral sense a moral tradition
moral grounding in
you know long long religious traditions
essentially when they depart from the
public sphere
it leaves a kind of vacuum and
you know wokeness is is a way to
sort of sort of paint by numbers moral
righteousness and it gives
people the sense that they're good
people i think people have an almost
you know i don't know whether it's
evolutionarily based but they have a
need to have a moral
character and sense of themselves and if
and if something comes along which is
going to offer that
and give you that thing well then
there's a there's a tremendous hunger
for it so people will adopt it quickly
and so you can have
you know a very small percentage of the
population that's pushing it can have a
real powerful outsized influence do you
do you have a traditional religious
belief of any sort and are you a
practicing religious person
i am i am um it's a really good question
i am i was raised catholic and i
you know was i've lapsed you know i i
have a joke that i
i use sometimes you know i'm so lapsed
i'm prolapsed
but uh basically uh i i
you know was a functioning agnostic then
atheists
uh and um but i
i don't feel like i really need a lot of
god
but i do need to have something which is
like a conscience like i guess i believe
in a conscience
i believe in some little mirror of the
divine which sort of is
is in me it's not like above me or
around me but it is within me and so
it's sort of like a reflective
thing that i can and it's sort of
reactivated
i guess and as part of this whole
experience
so i can i can take in the world and the
world of reality but i can reflect it
against something which is not of this
world
i don't know how to describe it and then
that's pretty good
what comes back i'm i'm i'm satisfied
with that
answer you know like what comes back is
something that i should attend to
it's something that is the it is it is
something important
and that is the you know and and now
that i feel like i have that
or an awareness of that you know it's
just like
you know ah you know
okay like i've got thank god it's been
there exactly
thank god i want to say thank god but i
don't i don't i don't know
i don't know that there's a god with a
capital g
i just know that there's something which
is
which is not of this world but is in
this world
and it's it's it's not out there so what
do you think
okay so what about
when i read you oh i have two questions
the first question is why did you
one of the questions is why did you
agree to talk to me and the second
question is what do you have to say to
teachers who are
wrestling with their conscience in
relationship to this issue
so let's start with that one
start with the second one no yeah with
the with the teachers what do you have
to say i mean
you already said you're not interested
in judging people for their
decisions but no you've been through
this you've thought about it like
what's your conclusion and what and your
your hope or
if it's not a recommendation maybe it's
a hope i would just say
you know stand up for the truth and in
whatever way you can if you if you feel
if you have that same reflective process
within yourself or you if what i'm
saying makes sense to you
in terms of your your sense of right and
wrong
if you feel that what you're being asked
to teach or what your students are being
are going through is wrong then
weigh that like like do it smartly but
but really take it seriously and
and and why why why why because
because it's crucial it's it's it's what
will save us
if you don't if you don't stand up
crucial
that's a hell of a word to use in that
context
yeah right yeah the root of that yeah um
you
you you know the
you're being asked you're being called
to do something
and you know it doesn't mean that you
have to
like run around and
and proclaim you know and save the world
it just means you have to do
something in a way that is constructive
and well thought out
and and will that will help the
immediate circumstances in which you
find yourself
and help to
you know set an example and if you don't
and if you don't
um well then it's you're leaving it up
to the next guy maybe the next guy isn't
up to it and maybe the next guy isn't up
to it and maybe the next guy isn't up to
it and then
what happens then then you've then
you've you may not get it you may not
get a chance
you may not get it all you can teach is
the words on the appropriate list you
could just be replaced by the list
yeah yeah you know i mean the thing
that's so wonderful about teaching is
that you get to make
contact with someone else with you
and so if that's being whittled away in
favor of
the approved list then there isn't a
hell of a lot
of room for you and it's kind of hard
for me to say
see how you could take any derive any
source of meaningful engagement from
your job if you've been reduced to a set
of
moralistic platitudes especially when
extreme punishment
accompanies deviation from them
so that's the thing i always noticed
when i was a clinical psychologist i
always brought
because i don't practice now for a
variety of reasons
there's a price to speaking
but there's a price to remaining silent
when you have something to say
so you get to pick your price um yeah
so why did you agree to talk to me
well i wanted to talk to you because uh
you know you've you've been a pretty big
influence on my on my life uh
i followed you from the you know from
the bill c-16 video
and um your your biblical lectures were
very very
moving to me i mean i i had never
thought of i never imagined even
that there was a way to sort of
harmonize
you know evolution and religion
in that way it seemed just like a
remarkable
achievement to to sort of
kind of find a third way out of
the you know along another dimension
from the
the conflict of you know is it true is
it not true is it true is it not to it
does and sort of saying it doesn't
matter
that's not the question the question is
like
why does this matter and and you know
what
i don't know the way he did it was like
it apparently matters
the question is why it seems to matter
um and it sort of reframed it in a way
that i couldn't
um that i couldn't ignore and that admit
it
because i was raised with these stories
but they didn't really
make sense in the modern paradigm that
i've been you know that
that i experienced as a kind of drifting
away
i think that my my experience in in
relating to your work
is quite common i think a lot of people
had this experience listening to your
work and your lectures um and that
finding a way to sort of connect with
myself as you know when i when i was a
boy i was an altar boy i studied the
bible you know these were things that
that were important to me but i didn't
understand them
and finding a way to understand them in
a new and better way was just
marvelous it was marvelous and that it
would have meaning for me as an adult is
something i never would have even
imagined was possible
um so you know that was
very important to me and also that
the importance that there is you know i
don't
i don't know it seems that
i don't it almost doesn't matter what
your religious
thing is but it it is important that
there's something
there's something important about truth
that truth is important and it's not the
same as reality
and people think that reality is truth
and a lot of it is but there's some of
it that's not
and that you and that being able to i
don't know whether this is something
that
that that i'm getting from you or that
you actually said
but i thought that you might you might
be someone that kind of understood that
where i was coming from about that and i
felt the sort of kinship there
and that's why that's why it was really
important for me to go on your show
thank you for talking to me today
thank you thank you for having me
my pleasure man
[Music]
you